[Música]
[Aplausos]
50 billones de pesos se pierden
anualmente en colombia por la corrupción
actualmente estamos en una serie de
reformas y debates en los que queremos
recuperar 14 billones de pesos que
corresponden al déficit fiscal
colombiano ya ustedes conocen el
proyecto de ley de financiamiento del
país y adicionalmente se están
presentando toda una serie de reformas
para superar la corrupción que tanto
agobia al país y a latinoamérica
para que entendamos un poco cuánto nos
cuesta la corrupción en nuestro día a
día como colombianos quiero traerles un
ejemplo si esos 50 millones de pesos no
se perdieran por corrupción en el país
tendríamos aproximadamente por lo menos
87 hospitales más en colombia
sacando naturalmente una cifra de 57 mil
millones que corresponde a lo que cuesta
la renovación del hospital general de
barranquilla en este momento pero
también quiero que lo veamos en términos
de costos de lo que nos cuesta en
dignidad humana pensemos también cuántas
vidas se han perdido haciendo una fila
dentro de un hospital porque no han
tenido acceso a los servicios de salud
porque no tienen una ps o porque les
pese incluso no los ha atendido en el
momento más grave donde su vida
peligraba
creo que todos estamos familiarizados
con alguna noticia en ese punto la idea
que les quiero compartir hoy es cómo
podemos avanzar en esa lucha contra la
corrupción
utilizando inteligencia artificial y es
una idea que surge a partir de muchas
cuestiones discusiones temas que hemos
hablado en diferentes grupos pero que
hoy quiero compartir con ustedes porque
siempre ha sido un punto de interés para
mí una curiosidad poder pensar en ideas
para el sector público y para una mejor
ciudadanía y una sociedad colombiana
hace muchos años con un grupo de amigos
en santa marta creamos la fundación
santa marta progresa que tenía por
propósito utilizar los mecanismos de
participación ciudadana y el control
político para luchar contra la
corrupción a nivel local y regional
dentro de todo lo que ha surgido de esta
experiencia les puedo decir que muchas
las ideas que implementamos ya habían
sido implementadas en el país y creo que
la conclusión principal es que tenemos
que innovar mucho más e ir más allá
esas mismas ideas las he compartido
también
en mis columnas del heraldo durante los
últimos siete años
semana tras semana recibiendo diferentes
comentarios de los lectores a través de
las redes sociales y dentro de estos
comentarios después naturalmente han
surgido muchas ideas
hay una en particular que quiero
compartir con ustedes hace dos años en
la universidad del rosario junto a un
grupo de profesores de diferentes
disciplinas matemáticos abogados
economistas analistas de datos creamos
el centro de pensamiento think tank
desde el cual buscábamos crear y aportar
desde la academia soluciones y
alternativas a los problemas que tiene
actualmente el estado pero no soluciones
ortodoxas como pueden ser por ejemplo
las reformas institucionales sino
soluciones desde la tecnología
soluciones desde la cuarta revolución
industrial
dentro de esto nuestro primer proyecto
se presentó de la mano de la entidad
colombia con pre eficiente apoyándonos
el desarrollo de su campaña 360°
esta iniciativa lo que buscaba era
analizar toda la información de
contratación pública de colombia
utilizando analítica de datos para
producir indicadores de transparencia
rendición de cuentas y valor por dinero
de toda la contratación pública en
colombia'
estos indicadores además nos permitieron
conocer cuál es cuál era el valor o cuál
es el valor de la contratación en
colombia pero también en qué ciudades y
en qué departamentos por ejemplo se
prefería modalidades de contratación
como la contratación directa
muchas cuestiones y muchos indicadores
surgieron de aquí y muchos análisis que
los invito a que los consulten
naturalmente en este estudio pero la
idea de hoy van más allá de la analítica
de datos que ya se ha utilizado por
ejemplo en este proyecto de colombia
compra eficiente y es utilizar la
inteligencia artificial algo que va más
allá de la analítica de datos y que para
efectos de esta charla definir como el
procesamiento automatizado de datos
normalmente cuando nos imaginamos a la
inteligencia artificial estoy seguro que
muchos acá han visto frames cuantos han
visto frente y de pronto recuerdan este
episodio
bueno entonces seguramente muchas
personas cuando les dicen inteligencia
artificial
se imaginan un robot tipo el que estamos
viendo en un capítulo de friends cuando
joey estaba conociendo este robot para
una actuación y nos imaginamos algo así
algo pintoresco que de cierta forma
puede ser chistoso y puede ser también
miedoso
y la inteligencia artificial ha tenido
algo que la ha hecho ver como una
amenaza para la humanidad porque los
humanos y las personas en términos
generales siempre hemos tenido miedos
pero qué miedos son los que más nos
agobian el reemplazo ser reemplazados en
el amor por otro o por otra y en el
trabajo por una máquina o por un robot y
tal vez eso ha sido lo que más se ha
creído en torno a la inteligencia
artificial
pero yo creo que es superando este miedo
podemos llegar mucho más allá podemos
empezar a construir soluciones digitales
soluciones desde la inteligencia
artificial que nos lleven a escenarios
en los que definitivamente podamos
obtener soluciones en contra de la
corrupción y en muchos problemas que
tenemos como país y en latinoamérica
quiero contarles dos ejemplos que creo
que podrían ser prácticos para entender
cómo se podría implementar la
inteligencia artificial en colombia' les
pregunto si en vez de desarrollar tantas
reformas que efectivamente no nos han
llevado a un nuevo escenario porque
seguimos escuchando escándalos como el
de saludcoop reficar o de brecha
pensaremos por ejemplo en un ritmo que
nos ayudará a prevenir esas esos
escenarios de corrupción o todos esos
casos que nos han costado a todos los
colombianos tanto
pues bien podríamos pensar por ejemplo
en un algoritmo que genere una alerta
cuando se empiece a concentrar un
determinado porcentaje de la
contratación en un grupo de proveedores
en un grupo de empresas o grupos
empresariales y que haría eso pues
naturalmente alertar que de pronto en
esa situación puede haber una hipótesis
de una situación de corrupción bien
porque no es natural dentro de un
mercado libre que toda la contratación
se concede entre unos ciertos sectores o
en unas ciertas empresas
pero también podríamos por ejemplo
desarrollar un algoritmo que despierte
una alerta cada vez que se supera el
monto destinado para una destinación
específica como por ejemplo si
anualmente se tenía que destinar en
contratación pública un porcentaje a
transporte si se destina más de esto
naturalmente aquí se deberían despertar
las alertas porque se está superando el
monto asignado a un gasto en específico
esto es como para que vean un poco el
alcance que podríamos tener y lo que
podríamos obtener con con el uso de la
inteligencia artificial
el día de ayer estábamos practicando
nuestras charlas de ted y antoni díaz
que es uno de los speakers que vendrá
con ustedes luego está por acá el es
matemático y yo aproveché
yo soy abogada entonces aproveché y le
dije bueno anthony porque no pensamos en
un algoritmo en el que por ejemplo el
segundo ejemplo que les contaba cuando
se superaba el presupuesto asignado se
pudiera generar una alerta y para los
que son matemáticos de producto es muy
fácil desarrollarlo pero para los que no
quiero compartir se lo visualmente así
se vería un algoritmo de esta índole y
es un algoritmo que podría funcionar con
inteligencia artificial y nos podría
generar muchas alertas en torno a
fenómenos que ocurren en torno a la
corrupción en colombia
a nivel global hay iniciativas que ya
han avanzado en este tema como hay para
price que es una iniciativa de la india
en la que muchos ciudadanos han
reportado los diferentes sobornos a los
que han pagado en las diferentes
territorios del país o los que no han
pagado pero les ha pedido la autoridad
pública esta iniciativa ha permitido
tener una trazabilidad de los pagos de
soborno que se han hecho y poder saber
cuáles son las conductas más repetitivas
las autoridades que más lo hacen para
poder hacer un seguimiento una
investigación y poder tomar medidas
pero además la universidad de valladolid
recientemente desarrolló un proyecto de
inteligencia artificial en contra de la
corrupción en este proyecto de
inteligencia artificial lo que propuso
la universidad vaya de valladolid fue
despertar precisamente unas alertas
cuando se cumplieran ciertas variables
que son consideradas o que pueden
derivar en corrupción como por ejemplo
cuando en un determinado territorio
persista un partido político por muchos
años afectando las dinámicas
democráticas
de pronto generando concentración del
poder pues se puede generar una alerta
en estos casos 26 de agosto 11 millones
de colombianos votamos en la consulta
anticorrupción está claro que hay una
voluntad popular una voluntad de la
sociedad colombiana de superar este
flagelo que nos tiene afectados que
efectivamente impide que se puedan
superar muchas cosas en colombia y que
podamos pasar una página de corrupción y
pensar en otros temas que deben ocupar
la agenda del país esos 11 millones de
colombianos podríamos aportar muchas
ideas en torno a la inteligencia
artificial porque esto jamás va a
funcionar solo porque necesitamos que
esos 11 colombianos por lo menos
aquellos que estamos comprometidos en
contra de la lucha en la lucha contra la
corrupción aportemos información
compartamos información porque es muy
importante poder apoyar estas
iniciativas
yo quiero invitarlos hoy a que no
solamente seamos 11 millones de
colombianos
sino que a este tipo de iniciativas de
tecnología para la lucha anticorrupción
se unan los 50 millones de colombianos
que conforman el país porque necesitamos
50 millones de colombianos para que no
sigamos perdiendo 50 billones de pesos
anualmente en la corrupción gracias
[Aplausos]